Hello!
The existence of
adversarial examples is a curse for AI safety.
Imagine you have a neural network based person
recognizer and it works well most of the time
but not for a person with this printed t-shirt.
Adversarial examples are examples of
data that look very much to humans like
normal data points but neuron networks
think is something entirely different.
For example look at this
Panda it is a Panda right?
Tthis is also what the convolutional
neural network would say!
Then look at this Panda. Ah, the
neural network says it's a gibbon ...
And the difference between these
pictures is not even perceivable
to humans it is this noise added to
the original image which here for
visualization purposes has been enhanced
a lot, but it's really just tiny !
So how can it be that these
very similar images differing
by only tiny pixel differences are so so
differently perceived by neuron networks?
Well there are some hypotheses for that and I had
the pleasure to talk about this with David Stutz,
an AI safety and robustness
researcher at Google DeeMind.
We were at the 10th heidleberg laed Forum a
few weeks ago on a boat on the Neckar river.
Here's my discussion with him.
So hello I'm here at the 10th HLF with
David Stutz. He's a very interesting
researcher and person and I wanted to
talk to him so see what he has say.
In an offline conversation you told
me that you were doing research on
adversarial defenses and you told
me that it's harder to publish
research on adversarial defenses than on
attacks. This I find counterintuitive,
so could you please explain me why this is
counterintuitive and how this is the case?
Um, so it's a combination of things
so first of all um the mathematical
property is that it's always easier to find
a counter example than to find a proof right?
So in mathematics if I have a proof I have a
published paper and I find a counter example
that's very easy right of course usually uh Common
Sense tells us I don't just publish a counter
example I contact people and kind of usually
counter examples lead to kind of improved proof,
so you can learn something from it.
But it's much easier to find the singer
counter example than to prove a statement in
its generality um and I think that very much
holds in security as well: it's always easier
to find a vulnerability because you only need
to find one right then to have a system and
then like in in computer science of course
or in machine learning we empirically evaluate
it but in in security and cryptography usually
want to prove that the system is secure and
it's of course much harder. So what happened
in adversarial machine learning in robustness
against such examples is that finding them I'm
not I'm not saying it's trivial um but once you
understand kind of the the the tools that I use
the optimization tools and so on it's usually
fairly straightforward to find Corner cases
and to build attacks that kind of are stronger or
that kind of are less visible or whatever you're
interested in the other way around however it's
much harder because you basically you need to
train a model where you can't find adversarial
samples and even in practice that's a bit ill
defined because you're like you have a method to
find that res all examples but this is of course
also an approximation right? You can't like you
have a machine learning model with like millions
of parameters it's not that you can find all
possible adversarial samples you only need
to find one but at during training if you want
to train robust models you of course you need
to be robust to like all possible adversarial
examples it's much harder task and then on the
on the on the academic side because it was a very
new field it just also happened that people didn't
really know yet how to properly review papers on
the matter um so security folks for example they
very new to this idea of empirically evaluating
accuracy the the machine learning folks were very
new to this idea of of security of like having
this adversarial notion. And so it just happened
that in the early days it was it was and it's
of course a subjective opinion uh a bit easier
to find loopholes and find problems with models
rather than present a method that actually that
is robust against a wide range of attacks and a
right range of problems and so I always find it
found it a bit more challenging to work on the
defense side but on the other hand if you like
the the the reward is also a bit higher right I
mean if you find a really good defense so back
then the M lab found adversarial training or even
even some papers uh before them we doing similar
things but it's very longstanding right it's still
the State of the art whereas attacks evolved much
quicker people iterated on attacks much quicker so
it's um it's higher risk and maybe higher reward
however you'll say it yeah this is a nice piece
of History because yeah something which is hard
defenses should be I think more appreciated by the
community than also rewarded uh in conferences.
Ae heard here at the HLF a lecture by Adi
Shamir on adversarial attacks and he presented
his dimpled manifold hypothesis I'm claiming that
this is actually going to be the decision boundary
namely it is going to be roughly the same as the
very close to the image manifold with a small
dimple underneath the cats so that the cats will
be above and it will have a dimple above all the
guacamoles so that the guacamoles will be on the
bottom part everything at the bottom is going to
be called by the Network guacamole everything
at the top half is going to be called the cat
what do you think of this hypothesis and are are
there any alternative hypothesis for adversarial
examples um yeah there are quite a few hypotheses
and a fun fact is that I actually so my first two
two papers of my PhD are more or less exactly
on the same question so why do advisor examples
exist and can we kind of find an intuitive
explanation um and so yeah I I found the talk
very nice um mainly because I mean he didn't need
to convince me because I was already convinced by
the manifold Theory I think it's a very intuitive
explanation um maybe not why adversarial examples
exist but it gives us basically a mental model
of how to think about advisor examples and in
the past years a lot of Works have built on
top of this Al model and and try to kind of
use these insights to improve defenses to make
attacks more effective and so on so I very much
enjoyed the talk also from the perspective that
he's of course a very accomplished researcher
mainly coming from security right and I like
that he uh he kind of stood on top like in
front of like a lot of laurates a lot of young
researchers and highlighted this as an important
problem um which I think if we would have had
that 5 years ago uh there would have been much
more traction in adversarial machine learning uh
but I still appreciate it because it also means
that that the disciplines are moving closer
together because there I mean people realized
very early on that it's like adversarial machine
learning or robustness topics out of distribution
and so on are security problems nowadays of
course people are working also on poisoning
attacks uh water marking and so on uh but in
in the academic world uh conferences journals
and so on also research groups we are still
very much separated and so for us for example
it was very difficult to to to publish in in the
security domain a very different style of writing
and so on and I think it's a good sign that like
very prominent researchers uh kind of realized
that this will be very important questions in the
future and also these are challenging topics that
that uh even laurates can't like solve on the
spot and I I really hope that that it's moving
closer together I mean there are already we small
conferences and workshops that that kind of are
in the intersection but I think it's it's great
if prominent figures uh yeah support this kind of
movement and do you think there's other notable
hypothesis or do you think the dimpled manifold
hypothesis is the one that explains most of the
phenomena and you're you're happiest with that I
mean personally I like the manifold hypothesis
I worked on it very much so uh it's very much
a bias of of from my side um but I think part
so hypothesis is always is a model of what's
going on we still don't know exactly why atelic
samples exist also in images I think the the
manifold hypothesis is very natural because like
this idea of images living in a low-dimensional
manifold of of your high dimensional pixel space
is very natural but of course now if we if we go
to LLMs and we think about language if we go to
crafts and so on the hypothesis might still be
valid but it might be less intuitive and so for
me a hypothesis is always always kind of tied
into what what can we use the hypothesis to learn
something new can we apply the hypothesis to kind
of develop new attacks new defenses whatever um so
there are alternative hypothesis um I think um be
there there is kind of this notion of features
that are kind of only slightly correlated with
your um with your how to say with your targets
and there's this notion that you have uh useful
features and you have features by chance right it
just happens that specific pixels in this finite
data set happen to correlate with your target but
it's not really it's not really what you want to
learn classic example is envision people work
on on these biases that you in if you see birds
always in front of water you pick up on the water
and not on the bird right so and you can you can
have a similar notion of of this happening and
this being exploited by adversarial samples so
and this is just one example so I think there
are alternative hypothesis and I think all of
some of them are useful in different respects and
uh for example this hypothesis very much informed
how today we think about proper generalization in
computer vision there are data sets that now test
this problem right we have in the training set we
have water Birds on land and land Birds on water
and then at test time we strip it right we just
you can see it as like an an adversarial way of
testing um and and for this line of work like
these these alternative hypothesis were very
influential um I think in adversarial examples.
I think the manifold hypothesis was still more
influential than others but this this very
much depends on what people are working on
and I think I always believe the more hypothesis
the better and of course there are some hypothesis
that you can find counter examples but in the
end we have still a very poor understanding of
of like these very deep models and I think with
like these really huge foundational models it's
not getting better so I think um I think there's
a lot to explore both from the Practical and the
theoretical side okay thanks a a lot I conducted
this interview at the 10th HLF which is short for
Heidelberg Laureate Forum the HLF is an annual
Gathering of 200 young researchers from math and
computer science and laureates of the most
prestigious Awards in these two Fields such
as the touring award the fields medal the Abel
prize and so on I attended the last year's HLF
as a young researcher and this year as a press
member the best things for me at the HLF Remain
the lengthy coffee breaks and social events at
incredible occasions such as the Spire Museum
of Technology or the boat on the Neckar River
on which we were on the interview which you've
just seen on this video and I hope you have
found this discussion with David Stutz about
adversarial attacks and defenses as interesting
as Miss Coffee Bean did we both hope to see you
next time so subscribe okay bye last question
will you attend the HLF again do you plan to uh
well I mean the main question is not will I or
or do I want to um but can I or am I allowed to
um so this year so I was last time here in9 as
a PhD student and obviously I could come back
officially as a PostDoc yeah so I definitely
I I I think it's still not well known the HLF
especially International but all people I meet
during my PhD during my PostDoc I always say
as long as you can apply right I mean there's no
guarantee that that you can that you are taking
and that you have have the privilege to come but
I mean there's no doesn't hurt to apply and you
can apply every year as long as you qualify as
I think couple of years after your PhD so yeah
please apply thanks a lot this was a really
cool motivational speech and I hope this will
bear fruit so yeah thanks again for talking
to me and uh have a great HLF yeah thank you